Wow
*visible disgust*
How do you do that and be like 'It's chill'?
A lot of other people have been doing their own spin on professionals reacting to things related to their line of work.
Now we're a bunch of visual effects artists, and today we're going to react to deceased actors.
One of the most challenging things you can do in visual effects is make a photo realistic human look completely normal.
In terms of trying to replicate a person that no longer is alive, this is the best that has ever been done.
So this is the one shot that most people identify as the fake Paul Walker.
They didn't do any sort of computer-generated face here
this is actually old footage from another movie that was composited and meshed back onto his face and re-lit.
Ahhh...
The only thing that gives it away is if you watched his neck and the collar of his shirt, the way his body moves
doesn't correspond to how his head is moving.
It's like his body shifts back, which would naturally cause your head to like rock a little bit and that doesn't happen.
His eyeline, it looks like he's looking way past the camera.
He's not making eye contact with Vin Diesel.
It looks like he's just staring off into the distance like...
His eyes are also like super sharp like that--
this like strip right here, the clarity is really high and I don't think it really matches the clarity of like down his
chin and shirt
This is the shot that everyone really recognizes as the fake Paul Walker
but there are dozens of shots throughout this whole movie
where Paul Walker was completely computer-generated from like the neck line up.
What?
They actually have Paul Walker's brothers.
They look like him just enough that they use it as inspiration for the performance and reference for the lighting
Whoa
because they actually replace from neckline up the brothers with Paul Walker's computer-generated face.
This entire scene Paul Walker's face is fake. What that's good. It's really good. That's really good. Yeah, I had no idea.
It's such a normal situation. So it doesn't trigger anything to be looking for the effects. That's crazy. Well, this looks really good
That's really good.
the only thing that slightly puts it off is the the chin and the neck with the collar like the shadows and like you can
See his brother this folds there as it goes like this. They don't quite have those folds with Paul Walker
You don't really notice it, you know what really stands out to me? The irises in the eyes
so your iris and your lens are like different levels and so when light comes in from the side of your eye it catches your
iris a little bit
so that means that the artists have modeled the
Internals of the eye and the iris has actual depth in the eye. Eyes are the portal into the soul and people have worked for
years trying to perfect rendering eyes. This one looks a little CG. The eyes I don't think work in that shot
This is where the uncanny valley comes in.
It's really hard to identify what exactly is off here
but our brain, after millions of years of evolving to identify faces, can identify that something is off there.
I mean this right here is just a demonstration of how good it actually is and I can't point out that that looks perfect
That looks perfect, man. Yeah, they have the cheek muscles flex like watch in a second here. Once it splits. Whoa
Yeah, they're like it punches his job as cheek flexes
Weta digital is probably the most talented visual effects studio in the world.
In terms of trying to replicate a person that no longer is alive
this is the best that has ever been done.
Oh, I have seen this. Whoa
Yeah, it feels wrong dude. This is like Tekken 7 right here dude. He's too gummy. He's too like, oh come on.
I can't help but think that Bruce Lee wouldn't be cool with somebody using his corpse to sell alcohol.
I don't think they nailed the subsurface scattering.
That's what I was gonna say too.
His skin looks - plasticky or waxy. If we had a flashlight here
I'd show you. You can see it right there. Do it on the back of my ear
So you know what I'm talking about where your skin lights up kind of like red. That happens across your face, your arm.
It absorbs light and scatters it. The skin itself is actually kind of self illuminating and
here it definitely looks like they didn't really nail that subsurface scattering effect, so it kind of comes across as like it's just a reflective
plastic skin. Turn your face towards me a little bit so I can see yeah, you gotta light in my eyes
I know just keep it closed now on the tip of his nose
What's happening is the lights actually going in and then
scattering a little bit coming back out and if there's light coming from this side and
There's shadow on this side right on the edge where the light meets the shadow of your skin and it leads to a slightly reddish
like edge
between the skin where it's bright and where it's dark and look at the edge of his nose and his brow and his eyelid and his cheek.
There's none of that slightly reddish tint, that little reddish line.
There's the perfect example of that red line of subsurface scattering.
This is it.
Like that's what I'm talking about where it's not about to single to see through things
It's also riding the edge of where the light disappears because you have a little bit that light that's actually gotten into the surface
That's now catching that that shadow right there
If you want it to be real especially when you do high key lighting like this
You need to model that and that's very complicated because you get into your skeleton underneath your face
It's gonna block all the light since we've all got they each either me
ooh, that looks really bad.
It is though.
It is, he looks like that one guy from Tekken.
That looked a lot better this one right here because because you're hiding detail, you know
You're you're you're kind of hiding it
But in the other ones is like you have you go real extreme on the lighting. It does a lot to hide your flaws
Hey ma
Look who calls.
Okay, wait, I've never watched The Sopranos. I want to see if I can identify
who's replaced here.
You've never seen The Sopranos?
Who's CG, the chair? Mammy?
It's her, it's gotta be the oldest one sitting in a chair
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I see the ambient occlusion around the neck
Yeah, Grammy neck, it's just hovering. It's a hover head.
It's a totally different color from the rest of the scene.
Hover head is a big problem.
Just watch frickin Civil War and like Tony Stark and Bruce Banner their heads on those suits. Hover heads.
Now look here.
What happened to the neck?
There's no shadow between the cloth and the neck.
And it's like the the softness and sharpness don't match.
Also her shoulders not casting a shadow on her neck. What happened dude?
What? Where's that bright light coming from?
Yeah, that's the thing. There's this bright light coming at the side of her face that's not in the rest of the shot.
It's not lighting up her shoulders not lighting up her arm or the side of the chair, just the side of her face.
Dude, they told her...
This is what we mean when we say match the lighting of the shot
you're going to do before actually shooting a green-screen elements. Oh, this is unmotivated lighting right, dude
They said don't move when you act just stance down don't move your shoulders or your head
How do you how do you do that and be like, it's chill the lighting chain that thought that the
Dude of the frickin light. Yeah the other side what happened just then
Wow
I'm sure there's nothing that people could do
It's like they got given the footage like slap it on the face now her parts on the right side
You're so right. Dude. They Corazon ttle flipped it Mouse on the left side horizontal
Why would they even flip it between those two shots and that E they had to it?
Looks like they were just using was given maybe they knew she was gonna pass. So like real quick. Let's swoop in
Throw the green screen up
get the pop out green screen by her hospital bed, maybe no I don't think
Imagine that's you and you're like, I'm feeling pretty good today and the producer comes up. So we think you're gonna die soon
So you want shoot some pickup shots before you go? I'm just gonna get all your emotional. You'll feel good today
I
Think the only person you can get away doing that with is Stan Lee
I have a feeling you're right Ren like it's it be chill to go up and saying lame be like yo
Let me gather those assets before you know, we're also making a lot of assumptions. Here. We are. It seems you one new freak
You in danger of becoming a good man
In the gladiator movie where an actor dies before the movie finishes production and they still have scenes to shoot with him
So, this is Oliver Reed the actor. What's his name? Is that próximo? Is that his name?
So I say so they took him for that one shot and put them into this shot, basically
It's just a collage cutting it out of one shot sticking into the other and like giving a little color change video Photoshop
Okay, are they gonna be there with ya? Oh
They have the production design. They did it. Oh
That's that's smart. That's really smart. That's that's going like all right, we have this crazy lighting on his face
Let's design our set for this extra steam. You gotta get so it can motivate the same shadows dude, the freaking criss cross
That's what the Sopranos needed. That's that's flawless. The simplest way to do it is the most effective right here
Grandma Tarkin, it's not grandma grandma tark. Have you ever seen Star Wars?
So Peter Cushing is the actor who died some time ago
and the only reason why they were able to reproduce him digitally in this movie was because they actually had a
perfect life cast of his face Wow
And they just that was just pure luck on their part. And so they're able to take a very high detailed 3d scan of that
Casting of his face to recreate them. Digitally. The lighting is great. The lighting is very good
They're doing all the things I'm saying with Lighting's like a strong side key light good contrast. They've got the good
Subsurface scattering on his skin all the technical checklists are being checked off here
But why doesn't it look why doesn't it look that good? Cuz I actually I think it looks really bad in my opinion
I think it really stands out. Well, no, I do too. It's like too floaty. It's too free elation
It's the most read the lips for me
The motion of the lips is the hardest thing to do cuz I don't know. There's so many intricate ways
Your lips can move and it's really hard to replicate that digitally
Everything else looks pretty solid, but you can always tell you can tell that it's not real. It's like an animated and gummy lip
It's just it's hard to say what have they not yet done to take it to that final step
This is basically the best we can do while still being in the uncanny valley. It's so good
It's so good, but you can still tell and I don't know what to do to make it better
I think the problem isn't how good it looks when it's still because clearly it looks perfect
Yeah, how good it looks when it's moving
It's the small things that happen in your face when big things happen like when I go ahh, you know
The big thing is my jaw opens up and you see that the small things that happen are my hairs change directions
My poor is stretched the plates of my skin like stretching to get micro wrinkles
Really in depth physics like the soft body meet physics sounds like your face, which is very complicated
That's where I think grand moff. Tarkin is failure. It's just very firm. He has like the skin firmness like a 25 year old
Yeah, a 25 year old who hasn't eaten anything in two weeks
If someone asked me to do this, I wouldn't know where to start. It'd be like the equivalent of like someone banging
Hey, I need you to go out the desert and like put all these little pieces of sand in order. What is it?
They've sent us
How again this looks very very good, but it does not look real but it doesn't look real when it was wide
It looked really good and then like she got so close to the camera
He could literacy like the makeup texture for like her eyes were like which is impressive
They had that detail that's like Roy. This is hyper sharpen high resolution. It's the animation of the lips
That's the best thing in that shot
I look pretty good to me though between the nose and above the chin this strip right here
Yeah, the shot just kind of confounds me her eyes kind of look wrong
The reason her eyes lack soul is because she's not giving the performance people aren't just their physical manifestation themselves
It's also the personality this is somebody trying to pretend they're Carrie Fisher
This isn't Carrie Fisher regardless of how much it looks like Carrie Fisher
I'm gonna show you guys something and see what you guys think. Tell me what you looks better or worse. What is it?
They've sent us
Hope that looks better the contrast is wow. That looks way better
Natural performance
Yeah
One of the far right is what they matched her to that was when she's confronting lord Vader at the very beginning of a new
Hope look how her lip pulls out just a little bit more in the middle the intricacy in the nuance
And I'm also there where these muscles are pushing up and this one's pulling out leading to a little more of a pronounced curve
that you don't have in the
Motion-captured robe one version. Yeah, that looks way better. Oh my god, that looks way better. Yeah emotion that nailed the motion
So this is a question for you guys and for you guys, I'd love to hear your comments
Do you believe people should own the likeness of their face?
Because theoretically I can stick Tom Cruise in a corridor video right now, or at least something that looks like Tom Cruise
I won't be able to say it's Tom Cruise
The town cruise because I would be lying but I can have something that looks exactly like Tom Cruise should he get upset?
Can he sue me for his likeness? Do we own our muscular structure of our faces? It's definitely a gray line
There's a skill and a talent acting it's more than just how you look
I love reacting these videos trying to explain all these techniques exactly if you have a movie a TV
Show a music video that you want us to break down leave a comment below. We had a bunch of great suggestions
We've made a huge list so far and we are going through we're gonna knock them out
So, please leave a comment. We read them all Oh
I have a video for you guys to see next it's one that we did recently
it's really cool and involves a motion capture suit and
Transforming Clint tell me about the video. Check this out challenge these guys. Can you transform from Optimus Prime into a truck?
And actually drive down the freeway. Wait, what do you mean?
Can you can you contort your body in a motion capture suit?
Link it up to a model of Optimus Prime and look like a truck. You don't look like a rocket
Can't be done. I guess you'll have to watch the video to find out